i mean [ __ ] fake news articles are
bad enough already yeah
with with how you know there are [ __ ]
anti-vaxxers and flat earthers and just
things that have been enabled because
it's so easy to stay in your bubble and
it's really like strengthen your own
argument it's a worrying time
it is it is definitely a worrying time
but i don't let it get to me
i'm trying to enjoy life you know i'm
just trying to live my best life the
world may be ending but i'm gonna have a
good time
still laugh at these memes i care about
what i need to care about
no more that's kind of how i like to do
it like i just think that
after a certain point if you just start
worrying about everything you're just
going to be [ __ ] miserable
and like i think obviously you know when
it comes to like you know you're voting
on
your politician your area yeah i think
you should care about that and that
should matter but like
beyond that do i care if a news
presenter in the u.s says like
something [ __ ] abhorrent i'm like no
honestly it's not really my problem and
i don't really give a [ __ ] like
maybe that that's i don't know is that
is that like elitist to think that like
i think it's just outside of my like
like you know i don't know to me like
stuff that goes on the us sometimes i'm
like
that's honestly not my problem yeah like
is that bad like
some people say that's like a like a
prejudiced or ignorant mindset where
he's like
i have the luxury right it depends it
depends on the context right because the
problem is that
the problem with that argument i feel is
that there's no way a human can care
about
absolutely everything true so at some
point you're going to have to pick and
choose what you care about otherwise one
you're probably going to be a miserable
[ __ ]
and two you're going to wake up and
you're good you're just going to be
exhausted and not going to do anything
on the day because
you just feel flooded and i feel flooded
enough with my own social media
right now and like and this is me
like where social media is so
intertwined with our jobs so i see this
stuff and i'm just like i can't care
about i'm pretty sure that's how people
become nihilists right they just like
they look at the world as like oh the
world is [ __ ]
i guess nothing matters i mean like it
feels like it's just been so much
like heavier as well since the pandemic
as well because yeah yeah you're just
trying to like get by
you know life's already difficult enough
and then shit's going on you're like
[ __ ] man like
i'm literally just trying to be happy
for like 10 seconds here can i have this
yeah i
i kind of feel a bit jealous of our
parents when they only had to care about
the [ __ ] that was happening around them
now i have to care about [ __ ] that's
happening halfway across the world yeah
like when i see like you know my my
parents get [ __ ] furious that they
changed the bin
size of like the council by like 10
lower they're like
oh my god this is unreasonable you know
like i just missed the days where i
could give a [ __ ] about stupid [ __ ] like
that yeah
now i'm gonna worry about like literally
like
cultural things to do with you right
yeah it's just like i don't know man i
i i want to care about everything and i
want to give like people who are
fighting for like legitimate like good
fights i want to help them out but at
the same time it's like there's so much
[ __ ] like [ __ ] going on and obviously
the internet has obviously made
all the information even more accessible
so there's so many more things to care
about
yeah i'm talking about global warming
right i don't waste too much food right
what's going on over here
there's a civil war going on in this
country and like atrocities happening
how do i
how do i like legitimately like give my
energy you literally just like to
explain everything
how to live yeah like that's that's just
life isn't it yeah
like i don't want to be like um global
warming is more important than people
dying in this country yeah
i mean it's like how do where do you
where do you draw the line and where to
start
well i mean i think you can like you
know pick and choose what you care about
but it's the difference between
being publicly open about this stuff
right it's like i mean i wouldn't say
i don't care about something as much or
as like oh it's oh my god this is so
tough to talk yeah i mean
it is it literally makes you sound like
an [ __ ] yeah you don't give a
are we gonna get cancelled for this
mail-in but no no but no i i totally
understand because
i feel like that's just part of being
human right you know there's
going to be people that's you know make
the argument well you're pro privilege
enough that you don't
have to care about it right but i i
would argue that
surely surely you can't you also
can't care about every single issue
happening in the world because you you
feel strongly about this one issue
because it definitely affects you and i
understand that but surely that means
that you can't put the energy into
caring about another issue i don't think
there's i don't think there's any person
out there living
any type of life pre like you know
precious or
not prejudiced privileged or not who can
deadass be in a position where it's like
right now everything in the world i need
to worry about because it's important to
me like yeah it doesn't matter who you
are like
there's going to be one piece of news
where you just like that has nothing to
do with something that resonates with
you
yeah that like that you really believe
in yeah and that you fight towards like
helping that
like i'm i'm down with that yeah at
least you're fighting towards something
it's better than someone just
getting up in the morning being like i
don't care about any of this [ __ ] yeah i
mean like it's
pretty what it doesn't really bother me
much when people get like angry
about you know like oh my god you don't
care about this but i hate people who
are like you don't care enough
about this specific thing yeah like you
should be so angry about this thing and
i'm like
man i'm literally just trying to get by
yeah like what what dictates like the
quantitative worth of how much do you
care about
some people who get willing to get like
outraged and like really
like to fire up their ass for something
you know and like you know obviously
we need we need people like that yeah of
course yeah although [ __ ] doesn't get
done i can't expect
any everyone to be like yeah but then i
fee i hate it when i see people like
blackmailing other people being like you
should come
you should care so much because because
the problem with the argument is that
there's no way to frame it without the
person
without the person who you know cares
less about the topic
there's no way to frame the argument
without making them making them
like look good you know because it's
just okay you don't care about it
therefore you are the [ __ ] because
you don't care about this important
issue
and i feel like can we just accept that
we are all human
you know we why we are all just trying
to get by everyone has different issues
some matter more than others but it's
it's
it's a lack of empathy you know we
in order to empathize with your problem
you at least have to
give us some empathy as well you know
and i feel like there's there's
there's just there's just like a lack of
empathy in that sense in that kind of
argument
i'd like to think if i'm being ignorant
on any of this that you know it won't
result in [ __ ] let's cancel the boys
but i mean
just let me know down below i'll i'll i
will read the comments so if i am
missing any like big point here
or i'm ignorant so please do let me know
because i would like to change my
mindset i don't think it's
i don't think it's ignorance personally
i think it's just like being honest
yeah yeah i mean i'm exactly the same i
try to keep it as
open-minded as possible about everything
um and
i've you know i've definitely changed my
viewpoints on certain topics
thanks to what people have said about
what's gonna discuss of course
there's words i like there's one person
who um because i think uh
uh someone tweeted me it was like connor
shouldn't say the word
crackhead is like a descriptive word
it's a bad word
uh because it apparently has to do with
a lot of um
you know like racial stereotyping back
in the war on drugs in america and stuff
and is used as a derogatory term so i
just stopped saying it that was because
someone tweeted at me saying
stop saying it i was like well i don't
really need this word like
and you know because i said it on the
podcast and you know i realized
afterwards i'm like
yeah i mean there's like way better ways
to describe that
what i was trying to that feeling i was
trying to get across without using that
and i'm like yeah i don't really need to
use that word i haven't said it since on
like podcast or anything so i'm like oh
i haven't said it ever and i just don't
feel the need to and i'm like cool
thanks for letting me know commented
like if i have a bad habit let me know
i'll try and get rid of it yeah yeah
uh if you're like connor you're fat [ __ ]
you i'm working on it
other things okay now the ones i hate
the most are connie you're fatter it's
like wow
thanks